what i did do was make a lot of
connections
in my early 20s tons of connections you
know network is your net worth yeah so
when i started to make money i was like
oh sas got money again or now yeah let's
do some [ __ ] let's do let's build some
stuff let's invest in some stuff let's
do some things
but
i'm actually you know the your early 20s
after college is the time
to
live with your roommates have no money
have jobs that you don't like struggle
everyone needs a struggle story you ever
you know the kid that like right out of
college he's 22 years old he starts
making a hundred thousand dollars and
he's he's just you know he's married by
26 and like by the time he's 40 he's
like yeah bro [ __ ] life has been
boring as [ __ ] yeah but that some people
wish their life was boring some people
were like i got kicked out and then a
bird hit my windshield and i had to get
a new car like that different strokes
different right anyway the point is this
they don't teach you money in school you
got to take it upon yourself to learn
about this kind of stuff clearly 60
percent of states and other cities over
there are not teaching you about money
so you have to do it yourself now if
you're in one of these states that we
talked about these five
magical
mythical states missouri nebraska north
carolina utah and virginia that are
actually teaching personal finance
there's probably a correlation to what
happens when people start to make money
with them managing their money in fact
you know when i started
making serious money i started making
100 and then 200 grand and then a half a
million dollars like holy [ __ ] what do i
do with all this money
and i realized all right there's
something called the 50 30 20 rule let's
let's use 50 of it for my needs 30 for
my wants 20 for my savings or paying off
debt cool there's a formula with that
then i started going around talking to a
million different financial advisors
what's the best advice you have for
millennials what do you think what do
you think and just getting all these
answers and i boiled it down to these
six principles of wealth which we have a
course coming out on valuetainment
coming out soon on how you can go from
zero to a million dollars um
in less than 10 years which happened to
me and it's based around the six
principles of wealth having a game plan
which is a budget for your money
eliminating high interest debt save that
money investing protecting your wealth
insurance so then you can be chilling
and you can be chilling like me and
that's why i'm doing this here at
valuetainment
so the bottom line is they do not teach
personal finance in school other than
those five states or they do not do a
good job of teaching personal finance in
school so it is on
you
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken